将Gemini 3顺利上线之后
Andrew Dai决定离开了
待了近14年的谷歌
Andrew的结论是
光是大语言模型
无法将我们带到AGI
我们现在看语言模型
他们的思维链
都是用语言做出来的
就包括Gemini
ChatGPT和Claude
他们就是觉得
这思维链变得越来越长
越来越diverse（多样化）
那模型就越来越聪明
最后就可以达到AGI
但是如果你看模型
做视觉问题的话
现在这些模型都不会数东西
所以我觉得
你光scale（扩展）这个语言
这部分
还是不够了解我们的世界
另外一个方向
就是你说的世界模型
这些lab（实验室）都是从
计算机视觉部门出来的
就像李飞飞和Yann LeCun
那他们的想法我觉得是
更偏academia（学术界）
那样的想法就是说
我要做一个新的模型
novelty（新颖性）很重要
因为对academia（学术界）
你必须要novel（新颖）
才可以发表文章
我觉得他们就是比较相信视觉
最近可能变了
因为LLM
但是我们这个是算一个
比较niche（小众）的领域
然后这次就是
因为很多researcher（研究员）
之前也包括Geoffrey Hinton
他们就是觉得
视觉是智能的关键
但是从语言角度来说
光靠视觉
不够有intelligence（智能）
因为动物生物他们还可以做
我们现在机器人做不了东西
他们视觉还是比我们现在的模型好
所以我们在我们这个公司
我们就是觉得
要把语言推理加上视觉推理
才可以做到一个模型
可以帮大家
可以帮所有的行业
你觉得做这个视觉推理的
其他公司
大家的竞争优势是什么
因为我看到DeepSeek
之前好像推出来一篇文章
好像也是很
similar（类似）的一些东西
他后来把那个文章给删掉了
对 其实DeepSeek的想法是
跟我们的很像
他们的path（路径）
有点像我们的path（路径）
但是其他的前沿实验室
OpenAI
Deepmind和Anthropic
我觉得
他们是越来越偏编程的方向
因为编程这个市场很大
他们也是觉得
你要做一个很好的编程模型
你就可以有self-improvement
这个叫递归自我提升
谁先把那个突破
那谁就先达到AGI
然后这些前沿实验室
他们都不想第二达到AGI
都想第一
所以其实他们有很多压力
做一个更好的编程模型
所以因为这个压力
他们就不是很看重
多模态视觉推理这个问题
所以我在Gemini的时候
我就感觉到了这个
所以我就觉得
现在是一个很好的机会
做一个多模态推理的模型
所以你觉得DeepSeek会是你们的
比较的一个大的竞争对手吗
可能是 可能是 对
但是我不知道
他们为什么把那个文章删了
他们是不是又换了一个方向